more teams and fiercer competition will
their dominance
end in this new era find out now
hello chess fans all you panzers and
fellow
deep thinkers my name is alex kirford a
financial advisor
team captain of edward jones as well as
the founder of the st
louis corporate chess league it's my
pleasure to welcome you
to the 2020 season of the corporate
chess league we've all had to make
significant changes and adapt our lives
due to the global health crisis that we
are in
we've had sports be cancelled we've had
schools closed
and working from home is very
commonplace
but my friends out of adversity comes
innovation and that's why i'm excited to
announce
this year that we are taking the
corporate chess league
online now more than ever
you have the opportunity to engage your
team
engage your company and strive
for corporate glory if you want to get
your name
on the square then you had better
be there team edward jones is ready and
waiting two-time defending champs
i'm excited this year to bring together
companies
individuals in a safe way and for us all
to have
a lot of fun i want to give a sincere
thank you to the st louis chess club of
course
the founders rex and dr jeanne sinkfield
as well as joy and lauren obviously
without the st louis chess club the
corporate chess league
does not exist so thank you very much
now i want to turn it over to mike who's
going to explain
the format and the rules for this year
thank you alex welcome to the corporate
chess league 2020 grand prix
the st louis chess club will be hosting
these events online
or at the club and all culminate at the
final four
at the end of 2020 in match number one
at 6 15
you will play the same opponent from an
opposing corporation
twice so as soon as your game ends issue
a rematch the time control is game 10
no delay no increment if your team wins
the match
your corporation will receive 20 grand
prix points
then we'll play match number two at 7 15
with the same format as match number one
so how do we get started please log on
to
chess.com slash live you
must be logged in to chess.com
live to accept or give challenges
now in your email you should have the
corporate chess league
google doc open if not please
open it now if you are player number one
you will be issuing the challenges and
the subsequent rematches so when the
countdown clock hits zero
that is when you challenge and your
opponent will accept
and the game will start immediately so
be ready to play
here's how you do it in the google doc
press the challenge link all right
here we go so now we're on
all right time it was already at 10
minutes but in case it's not
you just go down to more and press 10
minutes
that easy and and you look and see
oh that was my opponent st louis chess
club great
rated no this will not be rated so just
do that
and then just hit play
and then the challenge will come up
don't press play excessively or you'll
probably be played
with a different opponent a random
opponent so just hit play
one time so
good luck everybody cheers and
here's caleb demby with the call
all right everyone hello and welcome to
our live coverage
of the corporate chess league virtual
edition
as always a wonderful impassioned intro
from mike comer
and alex kirford also saying some words
there at the beginning
as well of course a lot up for grabs
here tonight
i just wanted to walk you guys through
that info one more time
so all of the games today are going to
be game
in 10 minute with a zero second delay
that's a pretty fast time control so
make sure
you guys are moving fast uh staying
ahead on the clock it'll definitely make
for some exciting games round one is set
to get started in just a few minutes
here
at 6 15 pm remember each round is
actually going to be a
two-game match against your opponent
so after you finish that first game by
going to that spreadsheet
clicking that challenge link then uh be
sure to offer
a rematch on the website that'll
flip the colors so you'll get the chance
to play the same opponent
with the colors reversed and it'll be
a fun two game match round two is
set to start at 7 15 pm so don't go
anywhere
after your first rounds of course each
match
in each round is going to be worth 20
grand pre
points and then you also have these
individual bonus games
in the extra section and those are worth
two
grand pre points total now
a little bit of a weird thing here uh
please
do not listen into the stream during
your games be sure to tune in after
your games have completed uh first of
all it'll be rather distracting if you
have me talking in your ear the entire
time
about random chess nonsense but also i'm
going to be going over the games as they
are in progress and so it wouldn't be
good for one of the players
to be hearing me talk about their games
and get any type of unfair advantage
of course we're doing this so you guys
can follow the action live once your
games are completed
it's going to be a lot of fun keeping up
with the teams saying who's winning each
match and looking at those games that
decided
all at the final moments so once again
two game matches game in 10 minutes with
a zero second delay
uh 20 grand 3 points up for grabs in
each round
two grand prix points in the individual
bonus games
and be sure to tune back in to the
stream after
your games have completed we still have
just a few minutes left before we get
started here
once we are ready to go i'm going to
play a fun little countdown intro
for you guys and then be sure to stay
tuned
on that google meet call nick risco is
going to be giving the official signal
to start the rounds so that's when you
guys can all
send those challenges click accept on
those challenges and get going wait
for that signal from nick risco in the
meantime i'm sorry i don't think i
introduced myself
i am national master caleb denby uh you
probably have seen me around at the st
louis chess club i know i've met at
least a few of you
uh before this and i will be going over
the games today
from my very own home in this
brave new world that we're living in so
until then
if you do have any questions about
getting around started if you do have
any issues
be sure to send them i believe abby's
way
in that google meet call and they can
sort it out for you guys
make sure you guys get everything ready
to go
uh in the meantime this as i said is the
format we've also got a lovely little
scoreboard if you guys take a look at oh
that doesn't look quite right just yet
uh we do have the lovely little
scoreboard for you guys to look at
uh so we'll be keeping track as the
rounds uh the rounds end
nick and our wonderful team will be
updating the scores here
and we can see who's doing well in this
corporate chess league
i'm really excited to be here tonight uh
this is a pretty new experience for us
doing a whole corporate chess league
event online
but i think it's going to be a lot of
fun there should be a lot of fun games
we've been testing like crazy to make
sure that this thing can go off without
a hitch
and hopefully you guys all have a really
great time we're so excited
to be able to keep this thing going
throughout this
health crisis i'm being told
that my voice is too quiet
so i am going to try and
raise that just a little bit
um okay how do i sound now am i loud
enough
for you now dennis please let me know
um in the meantime thank you again to
alex kurford
for that lovely intro he does a lot of
work um
putting all this together and nick is
telling me that they are ready to start
so once again nick is going to give the
official
signal to go one last recap game in 10
minutes
these are two game rounds and you can
find that challenge link on the
spreadsheet
as i'm sure nick has already walked you
through and mike
uh walked you through in that intro
video in the meantime i'm about to play
a very exciting countdown
and when the pawn drops at the end of
the countdown
nick will give you the signal to start
your games
good luck everybody and thank you for
coming out to play
all right everyone hello and welcome to
the live coverage of the first
round i'm not gonna waste any time here
i think we have
all of the games underway the first game
i wanted
to take a look at here is in the match
between
david chopin and eagle eye two two two
zero zero one i don't know the real
names of these players actually no i can
check this
yes it looks like we have matthew angeli
against
of course david chopin uh and they
are playing for worldwide technology and
bayer respectively
so let's see how they're doing so far
this is the first match i really wanted
to take a look at here
and by the looks of things this is
shaping up to be an interesting one
david seems to have a better structure
this b3
c4 and d5 these three pawns right here
all form a really nice
wall and they take away just a ton of
central squares
away from the black pieces so david
playing with the extra space here
that being said though black has found
really good uh squares for his pieces
with both of these bishops really
bearing down the entire queen side of
the board
uh powerful stuff from black as well
but you know in my heart i do have to
prefer the white side of this
just a little bit more because you know
you take a look at some of these pawns
you've got this pawn here on the c5
square you've got this pawn back here on
the e7 square
and they both just feel a little bit
weak
it's pretty easy to imagine if a queen
slides over to f2 a bishop back to e3
all of a sudden
you're gonna have a ton of pieces lined
up against this be the c5 pawn
it might not be so easy to defend same
with the e7 pawn and now even with the
h6 pawn as well these three pawns all
pretty
glaring weaknesses in the black position
so if
matthew i guess or eagle eye isn't
careful he
might drop one of these pawns just off
the board and that could be
devastating for his position but
definitely
shaping up to be interesting here one
thing he can't do
is get too far down on the clock he's
already down to two minutes and 20
seconds
and david definitely staying ahead on
the clock that's
going to be the decider in many of these
close close
matches it all comes down to who got
there with more time
uh why don't we do the rounds here the
next
up in the worldwide technology match
versus bayer is
sweet man where is sweet man we've got
him right up here
uh taking a look here it looks like
sweet man is on the offensive uh with
the queen
coming all the way up to f7 giving check
to this king
this is starting to look uh devastating
for black here i think that white
should be winning this game let's see
how we got here really quick um we had
a queen's pawn opening and t4 f4 it's a
pretty
interesting way to get into a variation
known as the stonewall attack
the idea of this opening is both of
these pawns bear down on this
e5 square then white develops the knight
out behind it as well
it's all about this square in this
opening for white
and then he naturally develops his
pieces behind his pawns
brings out this knight and after queen
e2 rookie 8
we do see white actually break through
on the e4 square
so this is something that black has to
be careful of if you don't push either
of these center pawns
two squares forward then you do give up
a lot of this central space to the
opponent kind of without a fight
so let's see how white made use of it
looks like he pushed to e5
a great move here like i said the point
of his opening
was to control this square and then he
occupies it with the pawn
taking even more space in the center and
now
this strong knight from f6 does have to
move to the d5 square
and while it's not as though the knight
is bad on the d5 square it does defend
some really key squares around the black
king side
and without this knight the black king
might end up being a little bit weak
we saw the move knight e1 in the game
this move of course
defends this pawn which came under fire
it also clears the way for this queen
to come out to h5 uh we see the queen
come to e4
instead this prompts g6 once again
this knight needed to defend this square
now black has to make another concession
the more pawns you move in front of your
king the weaker it's going to get
so this move does hurt black's position
just a little bit
the queen retreats to f3 its job on this
diagonal is
over with so it comes on back and now
bishop e4 so this is
an interesting little maneuver by white
he was uh creating what's known as a
battery
with the bishop and the queen lined up
towards the king's side
and then he did a little switcheroo
brought the queen back brought the
bishop
up and now he has a different battery
along the other diagonal
we did see queen d7 by black bringing
the queen up
and while white actually captures this
knight on d5 it looks as though white
was interested
in winning a pawn but i think this might
actually allow
some opportunities for black here you
have to be really really careful
whenever you have a queen lined up
against a bishop like this
it paves the way for interesting
sacrifices like even knight takes c5 or
knight takes d4
um in this case it looks like white did
have it all figured out because this
bishop on b7
isn't defended so if a knight were to
capture here the queen could just
capture
the bishop but okay rook b does set up
those threats now
and white of course maneuvers out of the
way to make sure he avoids any
complications
now the queen came out to g4 we saw
knight d
to f3 and the queen
retreats the knight comes back out and
moving a little bit ahead
turns out black was actually the one who
went on the offensive on the f3 square
and i think um an opportunity might have
been
been missed here just to to capture this
guy when
white would have to give up the rook for
the bishop which is an unfavorable trade
uh he still could have done it but no
ops against it and now with the queen
attacked
it is just a little bit too late to take
on f3
with the queen attacked no time to
capture back and so white
saves the rook that being said though
black did still find
rook takes e5 winning a pawn but now
queen c4
rook e4 and yeah this f7 pawn was missed
and
this is where we left off jumping
forward a little bit it looks as though
we had a sacrifice this is getting
a little wild and now white brings in
more attackers and
at the end of the day this move is just
going to be checkmate for white
sweet man arises on top of the
complications here
scoring a win for world by technology
let's jump now to
the game of wades here we have wades
against cross to pj
all right this one also in the same
match
between wwt and bayer now crossta
has actually already defeated wades in
the first round so wade's looking to
stage a comeback here
in order to win round two for his team
get the score back to level and
end up on the positive side of things
okay now bishop
d6 has just been played and at first
glance uh
the first thing that sticks out to me is
that white has one of these things
and black does not i tend to favor the
side with the extra queen it's move 13.
how did the queen already get lost let's
take a look here
looks like we had a scotch and black
actually opted
not to capture on d4 this is the normal
move here but i think d6
should be totally okay this other pawn
move that he played
now we have a take uh and knight takes
and now just bishop f4 so white develops
the pieces
rather calmly this is not a bad way to
play bishop f
or sorry just pawn to f6 now and this is
a move that can get you into trouble
uh whenever you move this pawn this
diagonal in front of the queen
just does become a little bit weaker and
a little bit more susceptible to
something like a queen
coming all the way out here with some
nasty checks at a later date
let's see if that's what happened here
we just had the knight come to c3
the knight come to e7 the bishop comes
out bishop
out to block the check we have a castles
takes
takes
now c6 and this pawn move pawn to c6
does turn out to be the fatal mistake
here now knight takes d6
uh with check on the king here is
devastating that's what was played in
the game
and black was so devastated by this
check that he just gave up the queen
immediately
and now upper queen white should be
doing quite well here and we see another
sacrifice of the rook so this game
well in hand for wades up next in this
match
is jarrazelski against shannon
shannon i don't know let's find out who
this person is
uh yeah it looks like shannon i had it
right the first time or maybe shannon i
don't know how to say these names it's
pretty difficult
okay let's find jarazelski against
shannon i'm committing
to shannon looks like we already have
one point for jarazelski
in this matchup and now they are well
within
game two here uh and let's see what's
happening we have a very
interesting pawn structure where both
players committed to a lot of pawn moves
early on in the opening
black kind of all over the board here
trying to gain space on the queen side
then the king's side in the meantime
white built a nice little triangle here
in the center
but also committed to this move g4
bringing this pawn out one step further
than maybe white would like it to be
white might like this pawn to be back
here where it can support the big pawn
triangle
but on this square it's a little bit uh
weak actually and black is already
beginning
to put some pressure here white
anticipates this though brings a rook
out to the g file in order to defend
this pawn and
yeah black is just going for the maximum
amount of tension
in all these pawns this is really not
the
total recommended way of playing the
opening generally
uh players focus more on getting out
these minor pieces
before making quite so many pawn moves
but it looks as though
uh while white is a little bit ahead in
the development of these pieces
uh white also has some pieces still
stuck on the back row
so it might not be too bad for black
just yet although i definitely would
take the white pieces here and we do see
another pawn move now if i'm either of
these players i'm definitely using this
time to get my knights in the game
uh get this guy in the game even bring
this bishop out to
this square if need be out to g7 uh just
need to get the pieces going all right
we'll let those players
stick to it now up next we have spirik
ik ik ik
against now this is just losing let's
see if i can find
this game for you guys that one is right
up here and while this is down to the
wire
we have a time scramble now this is just
losing with 33 seconds
spirit down to 17 seconds
it's going to come down to who can move
the mouse
faster that's what's really fun about
these online events
is you can start to play some moves
really really quickly
using those computer mice of course when
we play chess over the board or
in person it does take us a little bit
of extra time
to uh to move the pieces but online you
know the sky is kind of the limit
it looks as though now this is just
losing does have enough of a time edge
here
and spirik does go down on the clock
now these players do still have another
rematch to to play for here
so we'll see what they can do uh that
game
really coming down to the wire that was
an exciting one
let's see up next we have weed on 80
whedon 80 probably whedon against vindi
see if i can find this game as well i
have
so many games pulled open it's crazy all
right read an
80 against loner 20
and it looks like this game is just
getting underway here
uh so whedon with the white pieces
against loner 20 with the black pieces
and once again
we see another situation where the
players are spending a lot of time
moving the pawns and uh one slightly
confusing thing
about beginner's chest that i've found
is you often hear
stronger chess players talk about pawn
structure you know
it's like they're obsessed with it they
don't want to get a bad pawn structure
they want to get a
good pawn structure so it can be a
little bit tempting to try to move your
pawns early on
to you know get a favorable pawn
structure you know it kind of seems
logical
that you would want to move the pawns
but that's not actually the case
much more important is to get these
minor pieces we call them knights and
bishops
off this back row and into the game
before moving all the pawns
and because white did that a little bit
better this game we see white is now
tactically just winning this rook on a8
it's
trapped with nowhere to go no way to
save this piece
black could go night here and give up
this knight
but it does look rather difficult for
black already
another lesson in peace development need
to get these pieces
off the back row and into the game a
little bit faster
all right exciting stuff that is all of
the games in the wwt versus bayer
worldwide technology against bayer
matchup
let's check out meredith against doherty
now
i love the name odority i can pretend
that i am
irish even though i am born in illinois
okay what game am i looking for here
looking for stevert19 steve r19 probably
i can see
cell see if i can find that one i
thought i just saw it but it might have
evaded me it looks like this game is
over by
time out i do think the players need to
offer a rematch here uh
and while that's getting underway let's
see what happened in this game
looks like c cell did eventually win on
time by the way do you want to mention
and
we had an english and this is a pretty
interesting opening by white usually you
know we do see e4 and d4
at the slightly lower levels but c cell
n or knows what he's doing
opts for the english defense where he
controls the central square
slightly from the slide using all of
these pieces
and this pawn out here on c4 of course
this pawn and now
with this move e3 he brings this knight
into e2
and after that he's already controlling
this square
and now he opts to control this square
as well using these two pieces
oh and this just in we have another game
underway so that one
disappeared for me but i've got it back
now so pawn up to d4
was played and we do see some trades
and now pawn to d5 so while this is a
really
interesting move uh it's very combative
it takes away
this square from the knight this knight
has to move now but
it does block in this bishop on g2 here
this fiancadoed bishop as we call it
so with this bishop a little bit stuck
behind its own pawns
at the upside this knight has to move
out of the way the downside
this guy might be a little bit stuck
later in the game let's see how it
turned out for him b3
okay we see both players getting their
pieces into the game bringing the rooks
towards the middle
and now the key break for black is
moving this pawn forward to b5
it's all about breaking down this strong
structure
that white has constructed of these
pawns
so with b5 he's coordinating with the
knight with the pawn
and the rook all hitting this square
right here
uh unfortunately white can capture on b5
and does win a pawn in this exchange
but still a pretty good idea to free the
pieces a little bit
but after rook c5 we saw the knight come
back and then yeah black didn't miss a
tactic here with knight g4 oh
and their rematch is underway so i think
that game is gone i was just about to
say
pawn to b4 and white wins a piece which
was played in the game
so cecil off to an early lead in this
match they're playing their second round
now
up next in the merits versus daughter
match we have red rookie against
sweek i'm going to go with sweet where
is red rookie at
hopefully i can find this game as well
maybe i
can't i think i might just have a little
too many games
open here this one off my screen so
we'll skip that one for now
uh on the next one we have i am rounder
i know i saw a game of i
am rounders somewhere down here looks
like
his games are actually totally complete
already he defeated
his opponent jx sun sellers
i guess that's jason sellers with an x
uh two to zero
uh so a very impressive result from
imrender let's see how we did it
we had the roy lopez uh the originally
it was a berlin and then after a6 it
looks like we're getting back
into normal territory here normal
mainline stuff and then a really
really early d5 by black
so unfortunately i don't think black can
get away with playing this
very combative move just yet the roy
lopez is this opening
where white brings the knight out to f3
and a bishop out to b5
and these two moves are aimed with a
very specific purpose
they're threatening the knight on c6 and
the pawn on e5
so the knight of course is a defender of
this pawn white is threatening to remove
it and
capture on e5 in some lines and so
this puts kind of the most pressure
possible on the black center
and because there's so much pressure on
the black center playing these
big breaking moves like d5 are just a
little bit
premature here we saw white capture
black capture back with the knight
and now white does win this e5 pawn
black needed to focus more on his own
development getting things like this
bishop out
supporting e5 even more before going for
these big
opening moves now his king a little bit
stuck in the center
white brought a rook to e1 and i guess
the rest is kind of history here
wow knight takes c6 with a discovered
check
uh and that is definitely going to do it
for that game sorry knight c6 the bishop
comes out and then
white does win the queen and i guess the
rest was kind of history for this one
all right good game by i am rounder
going 2-0 early on in the match
uh what's the next game to take a look
at here why don't we take a look at
vins for chess that is the last one
in the merits versus daugherty match
let's see if i can find that one uh
so many games going on it's a little bit
crazy
uh vince vince i've got vin d
no vins just yet let's close out of this
i am rounder game
close out of this one as well i believe
see if i can find some more finished
games
all right i do see red
rookie now that was one i was looking
for a little bit ago let's see how red
rookie was doing
it looks like red rookie and sweat have
actually split their score
going one to one i think that's the
first split we've seen so far
uh and this opening sweat went for a
pretty interesting
uh pretty conservative setup by white
this is kind of what we call a system so
white is playing a kind of system where
he's going to play moves like this
almost no matter what black is doing so
it's a little bit more conservative
because it doesn't challenge for the
most
space but it is a very nice way of
getting your pieces out to squares that
you're comfortable with them
on making sure you have some amount of
cohesion between the pieces making sure
the pieces
are working together we see black now
expand in the center
and this move a4 i don't like this one
so much
white should definitely still be playing
developing moves getting the king
castled
bringing these pieces off the back row
this move doesn't
really help white's position too too
much
we do see white bring the knight out
this way this is not really what i was
expecting but i guess it makes some
sense
we also have sort of another maxim where
you're not supposed to move the same
piece
too many times in the opening rather
kind of spreading the moves out between
all the pieces so you can get
all the pieces into the game as quickly
as possible
but that's okay and we do see this
knight have to retreat now
and yeah black goes for some pretty
funny tactics here with
this move b5 the idea is if captures
and captures white would be unable to
capture a third time
thanks to the pressure of this rook
along the file that's why we saw b3
instead and now black is starting to
take over a little bit
and did win this pawn on c3
uh the knight almost gets stuck but the
pawn to b4 does
preserve it and black wins a couple more
puns now gives a nasty check
and takes over the center this looks
like a very well played game
by red rookie so far uh yeah and this
rook falls
and i think the rest is probably just
history here
black up two exchanges pushes these
pawns down the board
and checkmate's suick so good game by
red rookie to level the score
nice comeback there on that board
and then there was one more i was
looking for that i wanted to focus on
here
uh and that is the fins for chess game
let's see if i can find
vins for chess
maybe i can't hopefully that game did
get
underway okay let's see if i can do it
the old-fashioned way
yeah not seeing that game but those were
all of the other games
between the two matches i was gonna
focus on for the first round that is the
worldwide technology match against
bayer the merits match against doherty
and kind of at the midway point of the
round now we do see
worldwide technology taking a little bit
of an early lead score there is
four to three right now we also see
uh merits going up just a point
just a single point over dougherty as
well these are some close
matches so far a little
bit further down we do see edward jones
i believe
taking an early lead although it is not
totally clear what the result was in
most of those games just yet
why don't we check back in with uh david
chopin i hope we can find this one again
yeah so back to the top here with david
chopin let's keep an eye on this game
until it concludes i'm really interested
to see how this top
board between worldwide technology and
bayer turns out here we have rook d1
by uh eagle eye aka
matthew and
this seems to be a funny situation where
both sides are dealing
with some back rank checkmating threats
uh
white is preserving the back rank with
this rook for now
black of course has the option to bring
the knight back to f8 to avoid any
backrank mates as they're known
these are checkmates where the king is
attacked from the side along the back
rank it cannot advance
due to its own pieces but both sides
have it under control for a while
there's a really unique tactic here
where
black could have actually captured this
b2 pawn
i believe for free in the previous
position
it is a fairly unusual tactic there but
the point is if white recaptures the
queen
then black could take this rook with
checkmate so a missed opportunity by
david but a really really fun tactic
there
instead he just retreats the rook back
to c8 keeping an eye on his own back
rank taking a more defensive posture
now after bishop g3 white gives himself
what's known as
luft a german word or a flight square
if you don't speak german it's basically
just a square for the king to run up to
now if it
uh does get attacked from this back row
it will be able to escape
out through the h2 square
now black probably could do something
similar just play this move pawn to h6
give his own king a square
it's a simple improving move honestly
this position
is looking fairly level but it is a 10
minute game
without increment so draws are going to
be a rare occurrence
usually what happens in these positions
is the players keep making moves
until somebody loses on time and we do
see some more moves coming in now
uh david still not making this flight
square
for his king playing with fire a little
bit and now we do see him bring this
pawn out to h5
so now these these back rank mates are
no more the king
can escape and black has taken control
of the c file
white has taken control of the d file
should be fairly level
uh even number of pawns even number of
material
knight versus bishop maybe you can argue
that the bishop will be a little bit
better here due to its long-range
capabilities on a wide open chessboard
but i expect you know this one to turn
out to be a draw
okay let's see how some other key
matchups are going
we do still have no wait sweet man
has officially split his score against
mcnish
j.m mcnish jm
uh let me see who this is john mcnulls
got it john
mcnulls has split with sweet man i'm
sticking with sweet man for sweet man
because that's a really cool name
we also have wades splitting his store
score against crosta
one to one uh let's see how jarazelski
is
getting along against shannon i think we
had a really interesting first round and
while jarazelski has won his match two
to zero
we do see another classic
uh lawnmower checkmate i like to call it
you know
when you mow a lawn you do always have
uh
you know these lines going back and
forth uh on on your lawn
kind of the same way with these rooks
you know you do have
these roofs working together drawing
these lines all the way across the
checkboard
and checkmating the black king of course
in this game black could have blocked
and held on for one more turn with
bishop d8
but then the move queen h8 would really
finish
the the deal here in the game i think
shannon just lost
on time okay on to the next one
we also have spirit spirit ike
i guess against now this is just losing
we did see spirit unfortunately go down
on time and a really close match in game
one
game two still in progress here let's
view it from
the white pieces perspective and
it looks as though spirik is going to be
up a little bit
in this game spirit with the extra
exchange as we know it
that means one extra rook compared to
one extra bishop
and also up a couple pawns these two c
pawns seem to be extra
on the other hand though black is
starting to make threats around this
white king
so a lot to think about here the good
news for sprick is that she
has done a better job of leaving herself
with a little bit of extra time in this
game so she has some time
to slow down a bit think about the
complications now around her king
and be sure to find the right moves and
while we actually
see a sacrifice on the e4 square i'm not
sure
that this was required but i think it
should
be winning uh
i was watching a uh professional
tournament
recently and uh magnus carlson was
actually commentating
on one of the games and and one of those
games
a player did something a little bit you
know fancy in a position that was just
winning anyways
uh and his comment for that was showing
more creativity than the position
demanded
uh and i'm reminded of that here
creatively sacrificing the rook for the
bishop taking away its control of the c6
square
it's creative it probably does win but
it is
risking a bit much in my opinion uh
white now does have to find some
accurate moves it looks like this pawn
pushing forward
is going to be winning uh this rook is
going to have to block it
uh directly in front and then after a
couple moves
we can see a bishop come in to defend
and then this rook
can eject the rook from the back rank
we're gonna see that pawn promotes
and white should be winning but like i
said a couple accurate moves are
required here from white so let's see if
she can find them
i think the best move now is going to be
to bring this bishop out here
and she goes for the rook instead and
this isn't a bad move
but the problem is now there's no
comfortable way to get rid of this
rook sitting here on c8 of course the
downside
to the bishops is their inability to
switch colors
right this guy's always stuck on the
dark squares and because he's stuck on
the dark squares he can never really
impact this rook sitting on a light
square here on
c8 that means no matter how hard this
bishop tries it can't get rid of this
rook
that's why we needed the bishop to
defend the pawn so we could use our rook
which can influence both colors to come
to d8 and attack this rook
get it out of the way for our pawn
that being said spiric still or sprick
still with a winning position here
up almost two full minutes on the clock
fully expect her
to end up winning this game yeah black
isn't quite sure what to do
does come to h5 and now she does seem to
have found the winning idea with bishop
here
and i wonder if this rook will follow up
with rook to d8
and she has found it now and now there's
no doubt in my mind
with the extra rook at the very least
white is going to win this game so why
don't we keep moving along here
um i believe that more or less this is
the final game
in the worldwide technology versus bayer
match
and with a win here sprick will
secure the win for worldwide technology
it all actually comes down to this game
uh if
bayer were to hold this game to a draw
if now this is just losing
could miraculously draw this game then
the match would be tied
however spring up a queen definitely
looking like she's gonna win this game
it all comes down to this everybody
uh sprick needs to be able to win here
needs to not fall for any stalemating
traps or anything of that kind
and wow she has found the checkmate
deadly accuracy here at the end
no chance for black to stalemate and
with this
win sprick has secured the victory for
worldwide technology
by i think a single point uh worldwide
technology winning by a single point
over bayer
what a close match that was exciting
stuff
checking back in on the merits versus
docker d match it all comes down
to how steve r did against
c cell 0603 and that game is still in
progress c
cell up 1-0 to the moment it looks as
though merits has already secured the
victory here but why don't we round this
match out
um once again if you're just joining uh
there's
too many games in progress for me to go
over all of them
so i'm focusing on the worldwide
technology versus bayer match as well as
the mayor
or merits versus docherty match and then
i believe in the next round i'll focus
more
on enterprise edward jones express
scripts and ascension
hopefully i can have this uh
this flexibility i'm gonna do my best
here to to keep up with everything
all right so what's going on in this
game well looks like c-cell's
going to be up a full rook here so with
a win here c-cell
would go to a perfect two-and-oh on the
knights
not a bad result at all unfortunately i
think cecil's team
uh dougherty has already lost this match
with i am rounder
and vins for chess both going with a
perfect score
in this first round for merits
and now we see rook to c3 this knight is
now pinned to the king
unable to legally move uh white's going
to be bringing this rook to d1
to defend the knight but now pawns start
dropping on the queen's side here as
well the strip can capture
the pawn on b3 and this is fairly
smooth sailing now for uh
seesaw okay who else do we have
we also have whedon 80. wait
in the world white technology match
still playing a game is this true
is this true oh man i was looking at a
misreported score
it turns out vindy has only won uh
one game it is not two to zero it is one
to zero in this match i was mistaken
i don't know if i read that one off or
not and it is looking though
like whedon might be able to to win this
game
uh whedon here with the extra exchange
is looking pretty nice uh with the extra
rook you do
want to trade off one set of rooks here
the two rooks together they're actually
kind of redundant you see how they work
together
on the same back row here they almost
get in each other's ways sometimes when
playing against the knight in the rook
so rook takes rick definitely a
good move for whedon here wants to take
off
one pair of rooks and then outplay the
knight with the superior piece
the rook in the end game instead he
chooses to put this rook on d1
and this is an attempt at another
background checkmate a very common
tactic
but with c5 black has cemented this
knight on the powerful d4 square
and i think black is a lot closer to
holding a draw now
than uh and then vindy was moments ago
i think with this pawn supporting this
powerful knight on
d4 white is actually gonna have some
issues here to move rook to e2
is actually a threat that's why we see
this rook come out to e1
and now the trade of the rooks is going
to happen
and life for the white pieces is
probably going to get
just a little bit easier that being said
keep an eye out for the c
pawn this pawn right here might roam its
way all the way down the board
and cause white some very serious
problems
so we do see rook takes and pawn takes
and now
white and black both getting their kings
into the game that's good endgame
technique the kings
are active fighting pieces in the end
game because they no longer have to
worry about getting checkmated
themselves
we see now white expanding on the king
side a little bit pushing this pawn up
yeah king e4 is a great move you want to
take as much space as possible with a
centralized king
keep this king from coming too far from
invading
your position and now rook c1 and this
is
pretty accurate play from weed in here
you want to challenge this pawn
this pawn i think might just be lost
no real way to defend this pawn if you
try to push it forward
then the pawn is defended but
unfortunately you are leaving this
knight behind on d4 so with rxc1 i think
whedon
is well on his way to securing a victory
here by
undermining this knight on d4
okay so with a victory
whedon will level the score against
vindi
and with a one-to-one there then i
believe
uh worldwide technology is winning the
match by a
full three points two points
i believe three points
oh and vindy actually down to 17 seconds
on the clock i did not even notice i was
so caught up
with looking at the position i forgot to
check the clocks
and as usual the clocks are going to be
fatal
in this position you absolutely must
leave yourself enough time
for these complicated end games or else
you risk just
running out of time at the critical
moment
okay we do see king d6 now and findi
is just running out of time
um and we do see whedon 80 winning this
game
splitting the match with vindy and
to my knowledge that has concluded the
first
round i think all of the games and all
their rematches
have actually wrapped up here this was
the last game that i saw in progress
vindi
eventually taking this a2 pawn but
falling on the clock
once again those clocks are going to be
devastating uh in this format here
all right the time we currently have is
7 00 pm
we're waiting on just a few scores to
finish coming in here and then i think i
can show you guys the standings
um and after the standings we are going
to take
another quick break here while uh our
wonderful
td squad tech squad whatever you want to
call them
they help you guys get set up for round
two uh for the moment just to recap here
the scores
are still being tallied i don't want to
say anything before
my time but it does look like ascension
has defeated
express scripts in their round we also
have
edward jones it looks like etching out
enterprise in their big match
we also have merits i think i believe
defeating dougherty uh despite an
excellent showing by c
cell on board one merits does end up
with that victory i believe and then
from here
uh i think that's the end of the round
frank tan's game i believe
i do have this ability i'm sorry um so
once again
i probably didn't get to everyone's game
here uh the way i was doing it is i
focused on the worldwide technology
versus bayer match and the merits versus
doherty match
and in the next round i'm going to be
trying to focus more on those other four
teams that i didn't quite get to
in this first round but special request
for frank tan
let's check it out here he had the black
pieces and it looks like he
defeated his opponent two to zero an
impressive showing
board two for ascension is frank tan
against
uh n burdick from express scripts all
right taking a look here
we had e4 d5 the scandinavian defense
not the most popular these days
but a very solid opening to be sure
we do see black go for queen takes the
main line knight c3
and queen out to a5 sometimes you'll see
some really funny business where this
queen comes all the way back to d8
and lately these days sometimes they've
been putting this queen on d6 but queen
a5 i believe
it's safe to call the main line we have
knight f3 knight f6
both sides getting developed this bishop
comes out to g4
this is pretty par for the course for
the scandi sometimes you'll even see
this queen
switch sides once again coming all the
way out to h5
king side castles by whites e6
and c6 now for black and
queen back to c7 okay so bishop d2 of
course
lining up some threats against this
queen so the queen back to c7
this is the point of c6 i believe black
takes a slightly more conservative
approach in the center not going for
super amounts of space
but he gives all of his pieces homes
right they all have squares to go to
and that's the important thing in the
opening a night out to d4 now offers a
trade of bishops
black chooses to accept here and now
bishop d6
and this is some classic scandinavian
pressure
with this bishop on g4 that is now
traded off
it forced this knight off the f3 square
and with this
knight missing a critical defender is
sort of missing from the king's side
and black now applies pressure to this
weak h2 point
and it looks like black did not respond
or white did not respond
so after queen c1 black does break
through on h2
and retreats this bishop posthaste
making sure it doesn't get trapped with
any move
like g3 professional stuff now bishop f4
is offering some trades and i believe
rightly so
this is starting to look a little bit
scary for white so taking off
some pieces is pretty sensible if i was
the white player here i might even
consider
playing queen f4 just because my king
feels so
so weak but knight g3 instead and now h5
and this is uh kind of the the march of
doom
for white here this pawn continues up
the board
takes on g2 this rook sorry i keep
hovering over something this rook coming
into the game in tandem with the queen
is going to be enough for checkmate we
did see a trade of knights and then the
queen has to move out of the way
and now knight f6 does offer up another
trade oh
and my game disappeared why did my game
disappear
it looks like these players started a
little bit early
let me pull up frank tan's
previous game hopefully i can do this
uh or maybe it's just gone
forever tell you what i'll find a way
but i assume uh the way this game ended
was
frank marched on the king's side and
did manage to deliver checkmate
all right having to full up
pull up this game the old-fashioned way
here
all right let me sneak this one in here
with a quick update and did this ruin
everything
it did ever so slightly so i will just
quickly show it then
uh with the slightly skewed view and
let's see how it ended we did see this
trade
these knights came off queen up night
out to f6
there was a trade and now yes this march
of doom that i spoke of the pawn coming
all the way up to board
up the board and after pawn g3 queen f3
is check
and mate a really fun attacking game
from frank here
uh showing you the power of the scandy
this early activated queen
and then really instructive stuff with
this h-pawn marching up the board
to deliver checkmate in the end uh
really enjoyable game there by frank
uh okay back to it here uh wow
my thing is just going absolutely crazy
but i do believe that concludes round
one
let's take a look i think the standings
aren't quite ready
so we'll give them just a moment to
tally those up
and then when they're ready i'll send
you guys
back over to nick risco in the call and
he will get you started
for round two making sure everything
runs
smoothly until then we are killing some
time here
why don't we see if we can find some
other interesting games to look at
maybe there are some special requests
maybe there aren't i may never know
in the meantime it looks as though i do
have this gera zelski game still pulled
up
so we got game pulled up but we already
saw those two i already saw these two
pretty uh interesting symmetry here uh
white you know
winning this game with the rooks on
black's back rank and black
winning this game with the rooks on
white's first two ranks
um a pretty common checkmate here
just goes to show
all right the tan st the standings are
still being tallied
so bear with us for just a moment here
uh the current time for me is 707
so be sure to sit tight we're going to
try to get you guys underway
uh on time here if possible even maybe a
little bit early
but it does take some time some time to
gather all of these results
once again in the second round i'm going
to be trying to look at
the enterprise team the edward jones
team the express scripts team and the
ascension team
all at once it's a lot to do those are
some pretty big teams
but i'll see if i can do that for you
guys i want to make sure
i spend some time on at least every on
everybody
i want to make sure i spend at least a
little bit of time on everybody's games
here don't leave anybody out
all right taking one tentatively it does
seem as though edward jones express
scripts and worldwide technology
are sort of leading the pack here with
the most points
in the meantime just a reminder
everybody that's uh
when your games finish that's when it's
time to come back to the show
see what kind of chess nonsense i'm
talking about
hopefully you guys are uh maybe learning
a little bit
or at least having a good time watching
your teammates
battle for the victory
uh we also have a second round coming up
shortly that will also be game in 10
minute
do not forget to offer that rematch
after your first game ends
and uh then you know the rest is history
it's all chess from there i'm really
happy with how this first round actually
went there was a lot of
interesting chess and everything seemed
to go over pretty
smoothly so thank you guys for sticking
with us through any tech difficulties
you might have had
it does look as though things are are
going pretty well for us here
okay looking at these scores
um i think i can officially confirm that
worldwide technology
has won their match against bayer
worldwide technology
uh winning not the largest of margins it
looks like they won
by three points uh with
just one of these games being drawn i
think i think there was
one drawn game in the entire match and
the rest were
decisive results really fun stuff
uh against merits and doherty it looks
as though
cell won two points for the docker t
team
red rookie and sweek split their score
one to one
um i am rounder against jason sellers
managed to go 2-0
and vin's for chess also going 2-0 for
merits does give merits the victory
in that match the enterprise against
edward jones match does still seem to be
getting tallied here so give us a moment
on that one
express scripts against ascension we do
have a
split on board one between k muni and
dave anatours
we had frank tan going 2-0 against n
burdick and that second game by frank
tan of course the one we just looked at
a really fun one in the scandinavian
where frank
delivered a checkmate running that
h-pawn up the board
we had sean m sims uh going one-and-one
with maurice
gp we had neil esi against
s gilmore 999 s gilmore going
2-0 against neil for ascension and
a werner against ogave and they split
their score as well
so three split scores out of five games
or out of five matches rather between
express scripts and ascension
but ascension does take the victory with
two positive results in their five mini
matches
um so that one going ascension's way and
this enterprise versus uh edward jones
it's
anyone's game here i think these are
still being tallied
don't want to rush our team at all
they're making sure they get it all
accurate before i
tell you guys but it is looking good for
edward jones
uh tentatively here
okay not getting a lot of feedback from
you guys in the chat room i guess you
guys are not logged into youtube
talking so hopefully you guys are
enjoying the stream i'm kind of flying
blind here
if you do have anything you want to see
on the show
you can communicate that in the youtube
chat i am taking a look at that
or go ahead and pass it on to our team
in that google me chat or call
and i'll do my best to uh to help you
guys out
uh that team is trying to communicate
with me a little bit as we go here
so can make some changes on the fly
listening in glad to hear it joe
uh but yeah so just waiting for these
scores to get tallied
i appreciate it you guys i appreciate it
just want to make sure
that i'm not leaving you guys out in the
cold
okay so let's take a look at the round
two pairings actually it looks like
we have ascension against merits
enterprise
squaring off against worldwide
technology edward jones against
bayer and express scripts against
doherty
and i'm realizing that there may be a
slight
miscalculation in how i split
up my coverage because uh
that means i'm gonna have to look at
every single game in progress
to be sure we get some time to those
ascension enterprise
edward jones and express scripts players
so we're gonna have to
really be booking it in round two
um so of course in round one i did focus
a little bit more on worldwide
technology against bayer and merits
against doherty
so if you guys had your games going on
early on
and you're on one of those teams didn't
hear me get to any of your games
uh if you are really really interested
in what i have to say for whatever
reason
you can go back in that youtube stream
and go back to uh
to see the brief coverage i gave or you
know just go on with your life
it's not that important anyways uh what
i have to say
i'll thank you all so much for the the
lovely words in the chat
wow so much love from the corporate
chess league here
promise i wasn't fishing for compliments
promise
speaking of fishing for compliments
fishers of men
this score does not seem to be tallied
i'm kind of curious myself
what their score is so i'm gonna look it
up really quick
fishers of men it's an interesting
username
by steven evans here looks like fishers
of men actually
did go to and out is this is this true
is this live
i think no fishers of men scoring
actually one half out of two
against knock on wood ah but wait that
wasn't his opponent perhaps that's where
the confusion is
i don't know if officials of men
actually ever got to
play his scheduled opponent here this
could be why we're having a little bit
of trouble
with with the score
standings are ready to go i am hearing
tentatively
uh the question has been asked if the
standings are ready to go by someone
other than me
they seem to think that they are so i'm
just gonna show the standings
they're either right or they're not
uh okay flipping over here we do have
the scoreboard
and it looks as though tentatively
edward jones scored the most points i
think they have the most players as well
which does tend to help but nine points
that's an astounding score
after just one round for edward jones
winning their match
against enterprise we also have
worldwide technology
uh defeating their opponents bayer going
with seven and a half points after the
first round ascension
also scoring seven points uh very
decent score there we have merits
with five points i believe they did
defeat doherty
in their match all standings are fixed
and round two is starting
awesome we have bayer with four and a
half enterprise with four express
scripts with four and darty
with three with that in mind uh nick
risco has given me the go ahead
round two is about to get underway so
i'm going to
play our glorious countdown for you once
again and then
send you off to nick who will be giving
the signal
to start so good luck everybody have fun
in your matches
and i will see you shortly
all right we are back everybody that is
the
end of the big timer and
so round two is well underway
uh let's start analyzing
some games without any further ado here
so i have realized that in the first
round i just was not
going fast enough we need
to cover all of the games here today
because i do want to make sure everybody
gets the spotlight
on their game at least once whether they
want it or not
we're going over your chess games so i
am just going to go
down the list here starting with the
ascension merits match
we have dave anatours against steve r19
uh here is this game and it looks like
the first game is already over it went
dave's way
uh with a win already for him now he has
to
try and do the same with the black
pieces not always
the easiest task to be sure
so maybe i'll actually let this game
develop a little bit as they are just in
the beginning stages
we also have frank tan against red
rookie let's
take a look here frank of course with
the beautiful win that we saw in game
one
now he's already drawn his opponent in
game one
well underway in game two here in the
opening gonna let this one
you know simmer a little bit as well let
them get further underway before we take
a look
up next is maurice gp let's
pull that one up here
uh yeah and here it is i'm rounder
against maurice gp it looks like this
one
is still in the early stages as well
that's kind of crazy some of the rounds
in the early stages of the rematch
this one in the early stages of round
number one there is
a bit of a rating mismatch according to
chess.com here although that can
be rather deceptive a lot of these
players
fairly new to internet chess haven't had
the time
to uh you know kind of ground out grind
out the rapid games that it takes
to get an accurate rating so maybe i am
rounder a little bit underrated we did
see him go 2-0 in the first round
we'll see if he can repeat that here
against maurice gp
who is rated 1500 on this website uh
very impressive stuff
as for what's going on in the game we
had a
uh open sicilian meaning open
because white breaks in the center with
the pawn move we see these two
pawns get traded off and so the game is
going to be
a little bit more open oh i just punched
the microphone
a little bit more open and when i say
open
i mean open diagonals open files with
the trading off of pawns the position
always becomes more open
now we see pretty natural development
from both sides this is
just the classical open sicilian here
queen d2 and now
e5 by black eventually this move after
the move a6
is designed to force this knight to
come back a little bit back to the b3
square we do see it
and now we have the standard plans being
played in this position
uh white's light squared bishop seems to
have disappeared off the board after
this move knight g4
uh white may come to regret that later
that uh bishop
is sometimes important to guard the c4
square
be on the lookout for a knight trying to
appear on c4 maybe knight a5
to this square and without this light
squared bishop that square
can fall to black's control and knights
are really powerful on that square
in the meantime though white expanding
on the king's side now castled queen
side
that makes for an exciting game where
white can kind of go all out on this
side of the board just shoving these
pawns forward
trying to open up files and get at the
enemy king
interesting stuff by rounder so far
we'll see how this one goes for him i'm
not sure
if i can endorse this position
with the lack of the light squared
bishop and be on the lookout now
there's some tactics here queen takes
bishop i think
is already going to be a losing move if
white were to play this if white takes
this bishop
with the queen then knight b4 is a
triple fork attacking the queen
attacking this pawn on a2 attacking this
pawn on c2
in tandem with the queen there would be
no way to defend
all three of these threats and okay we
do see pawn takes then
from white instead this is a much better
move does not allow this knight to b4
because the queen does guard so uh well
done by i am rounder
spotting the tactics there uh moving on
let's check out s
gilmore's game do i have s gilmore's
game up here i
do against vince for chess looks like s
gilmer did manage to win
in the first round already we have
another sicilian the sicilian
really making the rounds here today of
course the sicilian occurring
after one e4 when black responds with
one c5
in this case though we have a knight c3
sicilian
uh now just a two nights and white does
eventually transpose
to the more open stuff by playing d4 um
white could potentially consider going
pawn to d3
playing the closest alien but with d4
these pawns getting traded once again
open sicilian a6 now and bishop c4 is a
little bit early
by white you're not super used to seeing
this move and black does take this
opportunity
to gain some space on the queen side
this is why this bishop doesn't come out
here
quite so early on because black is
normally happy to grab this space
using this b-pawn the bishop then did
just retreat
and black is now kind of ahead in the
race already developing out
putting pressure on this e4 pawn white
just castled but that does
sacrifice this e4 pawn and now after
bishop f4
this move pawn to e5 is going to be
devastating
for white uh s gilmore just winning a
piece here and
vin's for chess left trying to find a
way to escape
and does not manage to do so with the
knight falling black
should be winning in this game looking
good for s
gilmore uh up next let's check out
kamikaze knight
against of course david chopin david
chopin going one and a half out of two
in the first game a very very
respectable result leading his team to
victory let's see if i can pull that one
up here
should be somewhere i hope
is a little bit struggle with quite this
many games going on
and yet here looking at it it looks as
though
this one did not go david's way david
undefeated so far in the night but just
down the rook in this position
what happened here kamikaze knight who
did help us out in our testing events
and scored very well in those as well
seems to be back
to his usual business just destroying
everybody he plays um
very impressive stuff by kamikaze knight
who i know who this is
if i could just remember the name
kamikaze knight is of course john boyer
john boyer kamikaze knight how could i
forget
and while i was looking up that name the
game disappeared i
am devastated um all right we'll check
back in
with kamikaze knight in round two for
the moment round one did manage to
defeat david chopin
now let's check in with chess hulky
chess hulky taking on sweet man which
has folky
1-0 so far uh and of course chess hulky
is representing uh enterprise and is tim
neesham okay tim nisham with the white
piece is here
uh and what seems to be a fairly good
position let's see how we got here it
looks like
it was a silent white goes for this
interesting line where he
fianchettoes this bishop on the king's
side uh very often
in sicilians white has a difficult time
choosing where to place this bishop so
by theme kettling it early this bishop
is sure to have a home
and against e6 it does make some more
sense because it's come
combating black for this d5 square now
knight c6 d3 and we go for the closed
system systems of course closed meaning
these two pawns don't get traded so
files and diagonals stay a bit more
closed
in positions like these look for white
to expand with the move f4 eventually
let's see bishop f4 takes takes rookie
one
threatening to push to e5 95 not
allowing it to happen
knight bd2 castles now we did see
takes on e5 takes on e5 and b3
b3's uh i guess it's
just to defend this b2 pawn uh fair
enough it's a good solidifying move it's
guarding the c4 perhaps over protecting
it from any
pawn breaks black might be considering
but it does feel a little bit slow
knight f3 now and i really would have
liked to see white going for it
expanding getting more space with the
move f4
but knight f3 not a bad move either and
now white expands on the queen side
further with a4
and now just gets this queen into play
really simple
solid chess by both players here i think
they're playing a
a pretty good game uh
this is one of those games where it's
tough to point out
huge critical mistakes for either player
they're both just playing natural moves
that keep the game going and that's
exactly what you need for these 10
minute games
you can't spend all your time on every
turn trying to find the most critical
line
the most critical moves you just need to
play good chess moves at a reasonable
pace
staying even on the clock making sure
you don't go down on time
that being said h6 now drives this queen
away bishop out to e6
and we do now finally see this pawn to
f4 this is the key break
for white in these positions and now
after takes and takes i
don't think black should have taken this
pawn because now with this capture
it does open up the way for this pawn to
move out to e5
and with this pawn moving that suddenly
opens the door
to a monster bishop sitting here on g2
this fianchetto bishop just controls the
entire chessboard
on the longest diagonal available and
white will definitely
be looking to play e5 open this guy up
and play with the powerful bishop
in the game c4 was played and white
actually goes for
f5 i think in this case the move e5
really did stick out to me a little bit
more f5 though not bad
and notably this doesn't shut the door
on e5 forever
white can definitely still play for it
and he does so with the move d4
we have takes and takes rook over to c8
and white just contests this file with
rook c1
and king h1 steps out of this pin
we have takes it takes work over to c8
over to a1 now
b4 h3 and we have caught up with the
players here
so i think this has been a very well
played game by both players so far
like i said both players not trying to
go crazy just playing normal
developing moves improving moves to
improve their position
black now makes an aggressive claim with
this rook
attacking this b3 pawn attacking h3 and
white is definitely going to be under a
little bit of pressure now
black trying to claim that maybe you
push these guys a little bit too far
left some weaknesses behind but uh tim
not uh perturbed by this development
continues with his plan plays e5
once again opens up this monster bishop
is daring black to take on e5 when this
queen would be open up as well
all of the lines opening up now for
white it's
looking like this one is going tim's way
notably there may be a tactic with
bringing this pawn out to f6
when all of a sudden this dark squared
structure for black just kind of
crumbles
um and yeah i'm sorry after takes
there's just a much simpler tactic in
the position
this queen attacks this bishop this pawn
attacks this knight
now i do believe tim is just going to be
up a piece
uh as this game nears its end so
looking good for chess hulky here all
right why don't we check back in
we have big daddy jazz up next why don't
we take a look
at big daddy jazz's game always fun
looks like
unfortunately while i do like the name
big daddy jazz
the chess games did not go his way with
wade's taking him down in this one
wade's going for this type of scotch
gambit uh usual business against the
philidor i guess it's not really a
gambit
just expanding in the center quickly we
saw an early take
on e5 opening up this queen's file
very very early on now bishop c4 is a
checkmating threat knight
f6 defense of course a threat to the f7
pawn has been relieved
now castles bishop out to d6 and both
sides develop their pieces pretty
naturally
looks okay for both sides so far rook
over to d1
and then let's move a6 so i'm not going
to complain about a6 here
a6 is a move that you will sometimes
hear me complain about but it makes
sense here to stop this knight
from being an annoyance knight comes to
d5 instead
now h6 is hoping to break these pins and
we do see black
trying to break free now using these
queen side pawns to grab space
and slowly but surely evict the white
pieces from the position
and now all of a sudden uh white's
spatial advantage is starting to
disappear
with that in mind though this pressure
on the d-file does look
rather intimidating and after queen e7
we did see takes
and now fortunately this move would have
been forced to keep the bishop defended
with the queen
black did not play it it looks as though
white went up the bishop
and went on to win this game using that
extra piece and
oh well a fun checkmate to end it off by
wade's
this king nowhere to go black white does
not
bother to recapture the rook just
delivering the checkmate
instead good stuff impressive game by
waves
all right on to the next one we have
eritrean godfather against
gerazelski uh okay
let's check out jarazelski because i'm
not
convinced i can say the name what is it
what is his name eritrean godfather
that one is a little over my head but
jarazelski i can say without too much
difficulty we've got their game up here
uh jerazelski
want to know so far defeating the
godfather that's what i'll just
call him the godfather wow but in game
two this move
f3 not really a standard opening choice
and out after c3
there's actually actually already a
winning tactic here for black
but i can actually sacrifice this knight
on e4 the f pawn would recapture
and this queen can come out and this
check actually tends to be rather
devastating
already early on that's why we usually
advise
not to move this f-pawn out quite so
early in the opening you could run into
some trouble
but this was not played in the game
instead breaking with d5
and now black kind of returns the favor
playing f6 himself
once again though this diagonal can turn
out to be a little bit weak
bishop c4 is a good developing move c6
supporting the knight on d5
and now both sides giving their pieces
in the game and once again these pawn
moves i'm just not a huge
fan of it's much more important to get
these pieces in the game
any way you can playing moves like 92
just get your pieces out before pushing
the pawns
white though commits to it pushes push
pushes and black also
just engaging in some pawn warfare and
then we do see some trades
take on e3 a3 and so far
a fairly balanced game it looks like
more pawns get traded
and we're catching up with the players
now looks as though the white king is in
a little bit of danger
but i'm not sure it's going to be enough
for the godfather
to win this game now if i'm white
i'm definitely trading off these rooks
i'm worried about my king getting mated
so i need to get pieces off the board
and now the move knight b5
is sticking out to me here uh need to
remove this knight
from the threat of capture so i can
bring my rook
back into the game knight b5 is played
this is a good move by jarazelski
and let's see what the godfather has in
store for him
the rook is attacked and the pawn is
attacked but not to worry i think
this check is going to be able to save
both pieces
you remove the rook from the threat of
capture and attack the king
and then play this move and oh no a6 is
a devastating blunder
oh no this just leaves the rook hanging
and the godfather was putting on the
pressure in this game but it all comes
tumbling down for him
it goes to show you you know no matter
what kind of mafia you have
if you're part of the eritrean mafia or
you know the italian mafia
in the end the long arm of the law is
gonna catch up with you
in this case the long arm of the knight
catches up with this rook here on c3 and
it all comes
tumbling down for the godfather all
right
i'm so interested by this username i am
going to look up to see who this is
uh let's see if i can find it without
too much difficulty
on the enterprise team we have joey
mahari
the eritrean godfather the more you know
okay checking out
more games now we have moneyballing
against whedon 80.
moneyballin let's see if i can find
money ballins game
always a fun time
uh where's it at where's it at here
already looked at this game i already
looked
at this game i believe
not sure i can find money ballin
actually we'll give moneyballin some
time
maybe re-examine that one in the
meantime that
is those first couple matches taken care
of why don't we check back in on david
nader's and frank t
tan we skipped over those games rather
quickly looks as though frank titan
did defeat red rookie in his second
match let's take a look at the end of
this one
looks like he managed to win a queen
fairly early on here
and ah the sneaky pawn move the sneaky
pawn move has claimed many victims and
it claims another one here
of course the tactic is the discovered
attack
this pawn reveals or discovers the
attack of the bishop
on the queen and while it was just a
little pawn move it turned out to be
devastating for the black's position
here
frank winning a queen with this move and
eventually winning the game
uh back to dave anders let's see how he
did he did actually manage to defeat
steve r in the second game as well
uh a crazy final position here black
with an extra night in a rook let's see
how this happened
looks like this was another sicilian
game
turned into a sort of french style game
we do see some
funny trades here and oh my game has
disappeared
but i've got it back don't worry um
let's
look from dave nader's perspective
because he won the game oh my goodness
as games start i believe they just kind
of take over my computer
so i'm gonna go have to go fast to make
sure we get this one and after h6
i think this is a bit of a trap by black
leaving the night hanging because the
queen is stuck
guarding this rook in a1 white doesn't
fall for it though and then black does
move the knight
and now queen d4 and unfortunately this
rook did end up falling anyways
so white evades the trap the first time
but then
does move the queen anyways and that's
how davinators scored that win there
uh okay did we see maurice gp i feel
like we did
let's move on down now to knock on wood
uh knock on wood helped us with a little
bit of testing before this got started
anyways so let's see how he's doing here
looks like he's up against eagle eye up
against eagle eye who we may remember
from the first round knock on wood now
jd is playing with the black pieces here
he did manage to win
in round one looking at this position it
does seem like he's down the exchange
let's see how we got here
we had a queens pawn game looks like
white is playing a
sort of london system type deal but
rather than c3 he does eventually
advance
with c4 a slightly more combative try
than the traditional london
taking control of the d5 square black
defends with bringing the pawn out
and yeah natural development by both
sides and then ah the c5
move by white this is one that you'll
see sometimes it's not always the best
idea to grab
all of this space but it can be a
powerful weapon
if your opponent is unprepared taking
away so much extra space
b4 is called for to defend this pawn now
h6 generally you do see the black player
expand even further on the queen side
you have to battle back
for this extra space as soon as possible
so you need to play moves like a5 here
just challenging all of these pawns as
quickly as you can
and then even moves like e5 to challenge
this pawn are commonplace as well
gotta fight back for that space as soon
as possible h6 just seems a little too
timid
now after bishop here we do see this
rook on c8 getting corralled
and white going up the exchange now in
present day
white is still up that exchange and is
battling
trying to convert this into a full point
we'll see if eagle eye
can manage to convert this game
in this second round here of course uh
falling in the first match to jd aka
knock on wood
but hoping to fight back score a win for
his team here
okay we'll leave him to it now alex
garford
how have we not seen any of alex's games
yet
i'm willing to bet his games are
actually already over i think that guy
plays pretty quickly let's see where
he's at
looks like his games are already over
let's clear out some stuff here that
i've already taken a look at
i found moneyball in here it looks like
this did not go so well
for moneyballin making some early
mistakes
although this position seems good for
him rook takes a seven knight e5
wow he actually won the exchange but
lost this game somehow
let's see how it happened well now
bishop e3 okay this all seems pretty
okay so
far check check oh he was so close to
check meeting too and then the pieces
just started dropping
oh one after the other oh no takes the
night falls the rook falls
and from there black is just winning now
disastrous game by moneyball and he was
doing well
for quite a period of time and then
under the pressure of the clock maybe
did just end up falling to whedon again
whedon with a impressive score so far
um okay where's alex gerford i'm looking
for
a game by alex kirford i'm not finding
not finding it yet we're really
looking here
all right maybe i'm just not finding
we'll have to look
for alex's game afterwards i think
probably his games are already over
looking at the scoreboard here it does
look like he already went
to an o is that also the case for king
taker was i just too slow to get to
these games
looks like i was in fact just a little
bit too slow to get to those games
we also have vishal bardwatch that's a
difficult name for me to say
uh vishal let's see if his games are
still in progress
up against shannon that's a little bit
easier for me to spell
well it looks like those games are over
as well the players with a quick round
here in round two didn't quite get to
all of them
we did see fishers of men playing
against now this is just losing
fishes of men going 2-0 in this game
with another scotch game the scotch
making a lot of appearances here
and we did see some early development uh
white with a better pawn structure after
we did see
these pawns get doubled here bishop back
conservative stuff now
keeping those bishops on squares where
they can stay safe
but still impact the board now the rook
comes up
and yeah rook to the seventh just looks
devastating here let's see takes
or bishop b4 and now e6 and this pawn is
zooming to victory here this move is
check so it takes back
more checks and now white actually just
up two pieces
did manage to convert this game with the
two pieces
makes sense good game by fishers of men
okay what else do we have going on we
have teacher man
22 teacher man 22 did seem to defeat
vindy on the clock with the black pieces
here
under a little bit of pressure but it
looks like
he did have it under control with this
last move
black was preparing to capture on d7
it looks as though this game was likely
going to be declared a draw
soon you could have expected the rook to
come over the king to come over
to defend this pawn then maybe a check
back and this king
can't stay by this pawn and a draw by
repetition
may have occurred with best play here
but unfortunately for vindy
did end up running out of time
king taker crasta all right i'll be sure
to get to that one
i am trying it to make sure we get to
everybody you are one of the ones that
unfortunately the game's finished a
little bit too fast for me
uh we do still have a couple games in
progress let's try to get to those
really quick here we have k muni against
c cell
looks like k muni did end up winning wow
they played
three games i think that might be a
little bit much
but let's take a look at this one i
think only two games were supposed to be
played
they might have gone above and beyond
here um
this is a really interesting opening by
white actually it goes
for a super fluid pawn structure on both
sides
what do i mean by a fluid pawn structure
well it's a pawn structure that actually
offers a lot of options
it kind of keeps the opponent guessing
on what you're going to do next
so with a structure like this you see
how there's not a lot of contact between
the two structures you know no locked
pawns
this means white has the option to go
for stuff like f4 and f5 pushing this
guy
uh potentially white could push this guy
forward going for d4
potentially why you could even push this
pawn forward going for c4
trying to create some tension here or
even a move like a4 could be played
that's what i mean by fluid
just a ton of options for white and
similarly black has similar options
like pushing any of these guys forward a
lot to keep in mind here i love these
kinds of positions
so black actually did commit here and
pushed this one forward
and we saw takes and now white does
expand with this f pawn as well
uh oops skipped a little bit ahead white
expanding with that f pawn
now bringing out the knight going for a
king said attack with this extra space
we saw the bishop retreat now
f5 knight e4 and ooh this is getting
rough
this is getting a little bit nasty and
after h takes
g black actually resigned here i believe
the problem comes from this sneaky
bishop hiding here on
a2 if black recaptures he can expect the
queen to take back
and this pawn is unfortunately pinned to
that king by that sneaky bishop
so a winning position for white and
cecil
going down against k muni that's a fun
one
okay we also had ember deck against
sweat i believe i've already analyzed
both a game from both of them so let's
just keep on rolling here
running short on time we had sean m sims
sean m
sims against jason sellers uh sean
going 2-0 in this game in this match
rather let's see how this one happened
we had another french the french of the
sicilian the popular openings today
okay we had wow a ton of tension here
bishop d3 white does not yet commit to
this move e5 and now c5
why it struggles to hold together the
entire center it looks like c takes d4
just came at a very opportune moment for
black
not winning a piece but in fact winning
white's entire center
so without the center here white is
really going to struggle and we see
black use it to great effect
winning a piece already and just
converting from there although wait whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa what happened here this
was unexpected
um so white has to sacrifice this night
early on
now f5 bishop c5 we saw this move
knight g5 and then h6 probably missed
the mark a little bit
black really needed to get this king out
of the center this king has been
floating here for far too long opposite
both of these rooks
and after h6 knight takes bishop
uh black black ended up a little bit
stuck maybe he could have gotten away
with actually capturing this knight and
running the king to d8
but he was too afraid played knight d4
instead when actually knight takes d4
would have been really good for white
instead we saw knight c7 check king f8
takes takes takes and at the end of the
day it looks like it is white who's up a
piece
but the complications don't end here we
saw rook g7
a repetition of moves and then bishop f5
but
unfortunately this allows back rank
checkmate many a game
has ended like this looks like jason
sellers just ran
low on time and blundered at the
critical moment here
so sean with a back and forth game does
manage to go 2-0 though
congratulations to him we also had neil
esi
do i have his games here i don't think i
have
those pulled up anymore so okay running
back through
we do have a request to go over king
taker against cross to pj
so let me try and find one of those
i'm gonna have to do some digging here
all right nick says he's going to have
to add match points after round two
results are in
i don't know where he's going to add
those but i wish him the best of luck
all right we do have a game here
uh it's going to mess up the stream just
a little bit
but we will make
do looks like we just need
to shrink this guy down just a little
bit
and pull this guy out to here all right
working on the fly working on the fly
here so we had to cross the pj
with the white pieces in this case um
so let's take a look
crosstalk with the white pieces e4 e6
bishop c4
so already this is a little bit of an
unorthodox
opening here with e6 black is very much
making a claim
to this d5 square in the center and
unfortunately the bishop is not enough
to really challenge that claim
that's why we saw d5 come out on the
board and after takes and takes
this bishop obviously cannot take this
guy due to the queen's defense so this
bishop has to move again
and already white has spent a little bit
of extra time in the opening
moving this bishop twice now it's not
terrible for white but it is something
to maybe try and avoid
knight f6 now d4 is a good move
c6 you can kind of see how with this
extra tempo
suddenly it's black who seems to be
playing with the white pieces you know
he's making all the moves first and then
white is trying to catch up now because
of this
extra tempo we saw knight c3 bishop d6
now knight c3 is a fine move sometimes
especially with this bishop back here on
b3
it's kind of stuck biting on granite is
a common chess phrase
so biting on granite meaning it's trying
to attack this pawn which is so well
defended
that it's never going to break through
so in situations like this
you kind of have a couple of options to
try and get that bishop back into the
game
one option is to you know buckle down
and really try to
break through that granite and that
would oh sorry i guess i can't
can't make moves here one option would
be to buckle down and try to break
through
with the move like pawn to c4 really
battling back
for this pawn another option would be to
reroute this bishop maybe coming back
to this long open diagonal where it can
be a little bit more active
and so while knight c3 isn't a bad move
it does take away those options it locks
this bishop sort of out of the game for
a while
gonna be stuck looking at this granite
pawn
but okay the game continues uh nothing
too terrible so far
we saw a check bishop e6 knight f3 i
think these moves are are totally okay
and wow an early knight g5 now so you do
have to be quite careful of this
one um perhaps this is an argument not
to play this move queen e2
black can defend pretty naturally and
now
i definitely with my opponent's king out
of the center
would highly prioritize castling my own
king here because this file is so
wide open you can delay castling
sometimes
when the center isn't open like this but
with the open center you know this this
rook is going to come
down to the e file and it could spell
treble
so knight g5 was played and then i think
your opponent may have missed a slight
opportunity here
uh could have tried to play a move like
bishop
g4 and with bishop g4 if your queen
moves out of the way
suddenly moves like ricky h check could
become a little bit awkward
ricky ate first though and this does
allow you to get castled and now i think
you are
kind of out of the woods here h6 you go
ahead and capture this bishop
i do think this is going to be a
favorable trade
when you take off a bishop for a night
you're left with what's known as an
unopposed bishop there's no bishop to
fight kind of fight
for squares with this one and unopposed
bishops
can actually be really really powerful
things unfortunately like i said this
one is a little
bit stuck here but i would even want to
want to play a move like knight d1 here
just to move this c pawn out of the way
bring this bishop back to c2 and have it
really dominate this long diagonal
instead we see bishop d2 and just a
sacrifice
on d5 so this psac probably not going to
be good enough
i understand the frustration here with
this bishop being locked out of the game
but the psac not the way to go i would
have rather seen a move like knight d1
uh and even if knight e4 you just move
this guy
play this pawn up to c3 bring this
bishop back to the long diagonal
we see a p sack though and now it does
seem like the game is well in hand
for black here uh the game continues
with g4 and g5
it looks like but this is just a little
bit
of uh
over creativity perhaps if i could use a
word that doesn't exist
when you're down a piece like this it is
good to try and create
really really complex positions make
things more complicated
even if they're super risky but g4 and
g5 i
do think might just be a little bit too
much here we see g5 on the board and
after takes takes
you're kind of tempting what black into
taking on e1
but he just plays knight f6 instead and
i think this is a fine move
now after queen f5 you do end up losing
this guy on e1
and this looks like the end of the game
so the key mistakes here are this uh
kind of
peace sacrifice born out of frustration
uh this is what
probably lost the game but before then
this move knight c3
this very natural looking move actually
caused you
some real consternation and it probably
led to you eventually sacrificing on d5
move like c3 or even c4 with the idea of
bringing this bishop back would have
been nice to see
uh okay i think the games are ending
why don't i pull up one or two more
games we didn't
ever get to see a game from alex gerfer
definitely want to check one of those
out
and i think we also didn't see a game
from vishal
so alex and vishal definitely on my list
here gonna try
and find him you're welcome you're
welcome
it's always a pleasure uh and if i'm
gonna be doing this i guess i should put
in a little bit more effort here
go ahead and try and totally fix my
layout
uh it is just a slightly different size
on chess.com
when you do go to an analysis board
rather than
live chess that's why we're struggling
just a little bit oh
okay
hopefully this is just a quick fix
doesn't have to look perfect
just want you guys to be able to see
everything
okay got this here
and we'll make it a little bit bigger
all right that's as perfect as it is
going to get
okay on to the next one let's check out
one of alex curford's games
don't think i got a chance to see any of
his here today
alex of course uh one of the founders if
not
the only founder of the corporate trust
league
so definitely want to give him his
uh moment in the spotlight here where he
went to an
oh against mc uh nick j
nick jm for some reason this game is
this name is really difficult for me to
pronounce okay
grabbing this game here let's pull it up
absolutely sweet man absolutely i'm
gonna try to get to everybody's game at
least
a little bit i believe i spent some time
in an earlier round going over
some of your games sweet man because i
do remember that username
quite distinctly um but yeah i'll be
sure to check out your last game
so what happened here sorry i keep going
back and forth because it's getting
difficult for me to focus
all right we did see a very unorthodox
uh
opening from mc here with b3 and this is
one of those more conservative openings
where white can do a very similar thing
no matter what black plays
that's totally okay though we see d4 now
knight f3
and bishop out to b4 so already
black or white is getting into a little
bit of trouble uh with
this nasty looking pin on this knight
here now it's not
anything devastating yet but it is
something to look out for and after
bishop b5 i think this move
knight to e4 could have already been
pretty nasty i think
queen d3 is barely holding on for white
but 94 was played queen d3 was played
how about that
these players on top of it here today
and then we did just see
some trades and eventually queen a5
so this move is threatening to capture
this bishop also putting some pressure
on the bishop on b5
i did just see a capture here and now
after knight takes
black alex just continues to bully these
white pieces around
and takes on c2 proving that this queen
is a little bit
overworked between guarding the knight
and guarding
the bishop so king f1 has to be played
well actually i think rather
uh no yeah this move is check sorry so
this move wins for a number of reasons
and alex does pick up this rook and i
assume managed to go on to win the game
so yeah some slight mistakes here from
white a little bit early on
the problem is he just made some loose
pieces right
this knight attacked once defended once
that makes it a loose piece if you add
just one more attacker to this knight
then it's already going to be in danger
and with bishop here
this piece is also already becoming
loose because
it may look like it has a defender
that's a fake defender because this
knight is pinned
and so alex making use of the loose
pieces
and the uncastled king and does manage
to
win with a nice tactic here all right
let's check out
sweet man's game now if i can
find it
looks like we are looking for chess
hulky against
sweet man this is of course tim neesham
uh against
sweet man whose name is escaping me
right now but that's okay because this
username is good enough
looks like this one went well all right
taking a look here we had another
sicilian
with an early e6 e6 a6 and knight c6
and uh tim does go for the more closed
sicilian positions
with the fianchetto bishop and an early
d3 once again
look for white to be expanding on the
king's side in this game and black to be
expanding on the queen side here
white wants that king side space with
this strong fiance bishop
black in the meantime has already made a
claim on the queen side and will look to
expand even further
we had queen c7 in this case castles
knight out to f6
and early bishop f4 challenges this
queen
bishop d6 takes takes rookie 1 95
and wait a second i remember this game i
saw this
i saw all of this so far the queen came
back to c7
we saw i i was certain that tim was
going to win this game
we saw f4 and now c4 but yeah f5 came on
the board
d4 and it looks as though that's um
after takes and takes i was just saying
that i did like white's position
after this move e5 i thought up to this
point both players had played really
natural chess
really good chess um the one move i
wanted to comment on sweet man was
you did capture this pawn on f4 and i
think this event
may have been kind of a critical mistake
here uh
with this pawn on e4 sorry let me
go back slightly unintentional here
with this pawn on e4 if i can catch back
up
uh this guy right here this bishop is
really stuck
behind its own pawns it's worse than the
biting on granite we saw in that other
game
because you can never capture your own
pawn so as long as this guy remains here
this bishop is going to suffer
a little bit and by taking on f4 you
start to give white
some ideas of pushing this guy forward
when all of a sudden this bishop is
going to become a monster on the long
diagonal so i would definitely
try and avoid taking on f4 unless you
have something to gain from it pretty
immediately
in the game it didn't go so well as e5
for your opponent did end up
being more or less a winning move
attacking this knight and breaking
through
opening up this bishop opening up this
queen and after takes takes again bishop
c6
white did capture the extra piece but
from here it looks like you battled back
queen f2 and this does hang the h3 pawn
and just when i left your game
you went crazy with all of the white
pieces hanging
it looks like tim probably should have
recaptured this either with the king or
maybe
even what the knight could be considered
after this it does get a little bit
awkward maybe the move knight f3
was required here but from there it
looks like
you did well and rook takes h3 you did
just pick up this knight saving your own
rook there was a check
came up to h7 and now you're just up a
couple pawns
and while with this check you pick up
the queen as well and that is going to
the match
what a comeback by sweet man i had
written this game off
i saw you know the piece drop and i said
that's it tim's got this one
but sweet man battling back does take
out tim aka chess hulky in this game
all right there's one more that i
absolutely want to get to that is the
game of vishal
bird what i can't say his name vishal
we'll stick with vishal
because i don't think i've seen any of
the shoals games yet today
so give him a moment of fun
and then maybe check out the standings
oops looks like i misspelled something
as i
tend to do on occasion
ah it's a dash not a hyphen no it is a
hyphen
not an underscore rookie mistake it
looks like vishal did well
winning both of his games against
shannon here
uh checking in we've got
this game here by the shaw with the
black pieces against shannon while
vishal a high rated player
um and we do once again see this early
f3 move and i just don't really like
this move because it weakens
not only this diagonal but also this
diagonal you need this pawn back here
to guard some of these weaknesses
without it you might start to suffer
we saw black just stay calm developing
all the pieces
and eventual d4 and then while already
white
sacrificing this night i don't think
this one was required
i think this knight should have just
retreated but giving up the knight
instead
and now up a piece oh and now upper
queen yeah just an unfortunate game for
shannon uh well uh
not too much to say in the way of
mistakes for black here um
when you win a ton of material uh you do
tend to have a better shot of winning
the game so good game to vishal i guess
all right let's check back in with my
crack team
see if they're trying to talk to me
sometimes they are
it looks like the standings are already
st sitting there ready for me let's flip
on over
see what we've got and boy oh boy are
those some
standings over here we've got the
scoreboard
it is edward jones coming in with the
most points
at 63 uh total board points and that is
how many points they scored overall from
all of the matches
we also have ascension with 56 and a
half actually in a tie
with worldwide technology that's kind of
crazy that they would tie
exactly at 56 and a half well done to
both of those teams
well deserved we have express scripts
with 33
merits with 25 and a half enterprise
with nine bayer with four and a half and
doherty
with four thank you guys all so much
for playing um oops shouldn't have
clicked on that
let's just go back here uh in the
meantime i guess
what this means i can briefly look at
this
format for a little bit uh once again
there were a ton of grand prix points up
for grabs here
for the corporate chess league and
looking around it looks like
in round one worldwide technology
winning their match against bayer
is the recipient of some grand prix
points we also had merits
defeating dougherty to get their own
grand prix points as well
we had edward jones defeating enterprise
for the grand prix points
and we had ascension defeating express
scripts for those 20 points and then in
round
two we had i think a similar story
we had uh ascension defeating merits
uh bringing their total i think to 40
grand prix points if i'm not mistaken
so a perfect 2-0 match record for
ascension
we had enterprise uh just barely falling
to worldwide technology so worldwide
technology also
with 40 grand pre-points uh
congratulations
we had edward jones clean sweeping bayer
oh my goodness gracious
that is a crazy score edward jones with
the perfect match score against bayer
so they also uh go to
40 grand three points winning both of
their matches with express scripts
defeating docherty
and then four players in the extra
matches section
i'm not totally certain how those extra
players
do end up contributing to the grand prix
points but they do somehow
ask mike cummer on that one uh
well i think that does just about
conclude
our show here um thank you guys
so much for tuning in to this live
coverage of the corporate chess league i
had a great time
covering the games hopefully you all
enjoyed playing this
virtual formats uh and we will see you
next time uh for another edition of the
corporate chess league
goodbye everyone